CARTER MORGAN: Welcome to "Cloud
Security Basics," a new series
where we explain the
ins and outs of securing
your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around,
because in this episode,
you'll learn how Google Cloud
protects customers' data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[DIALING]
BRAD ACTOR: Hello,
cloud detective.
You may have answered basic
questions about platform
security, but what do you know
about how Google Cloud secures
data inside of its platform?
As you hit send on your keyboard
and send data over the network,
one of my hench people
could intercept that data,
or I could plant malware
inside of your system
to nefariously do my bidding.
What can you do to stop that?
For your sake, I hope you know
the answer to my question.
CARTER MORGAN: OK,
here's what we know.
This comes down to
securing data at rest
and securing data in transit.
When Brad Actor talks
about a malicious service
inside of your system gaining
access to your other services,
there are a lot of ways
Google protects from that.
For one, to keep data
private and secure,
Google logically isolates
each customer's data
from that of other
customers and users,
even when it's stored on
the same physical server.
As Google is managing this
for its cloud clients,
it protects them from
employees abusing their access.
Only a small group
of Google employees
ever have access
to customer data.
Additionally, Google
doesn't scan customer data
for advertisements or
sell it to third parties.
And then if customers
delete their data,
Google commits to deleting
it from their systems
within 180 days.
Finally, Google provides tools
that make it easy for customers
to take their data with
them if they ever choose
to stop using Google services.
These are just a
few examples of how
Google Cloud protects
customer data that
lives in Google Cloud.
Let's look at a few more.
So how does Google Cloud protect
from data being intercepted
as it's sent over the network?
Before we answer that, let's
talk about data at rest.
When users store their
data in Google Cloud,
the various Google
Cloud Storage services
can be configured to use keys
from a central key management
service to encrypt
data before it's
written to physical storage.
Performing encryption
at the application layer
allows the infrastructure
to isolate itself
from potential
threats at the lower
levels of storage, such as
a malicious disk firmware.
Other layers of
protections are also used,
such as hardware encryption.
But once data leaves
Google's secure server,
customer data must
make several journeys
across devices, known as hops,
across the public internet.
The number of hops
depends on the distance
between the customer's ISP and
the solution's data center.
Each additional hop introduces
a new opportunity for data
to be attacked or intercepted.
Because it's linked to
most ISPs in the world,
though, Google's global
network improves the security
of data in transit
by limiting hops
across the public internet.
All traffic is routed through
custom Google front end
servers.
Google front end servers
are used to detect and stop
malicious requests
and distributed
denial of service attacks.
Additionally, GFE
servers are only
allowed to communicate with
the control list of servers
internally.
This default deny configuration
prevents GFC servers
from accessing
unintended resources.
As the data moves
along the network,
Google uses cryptography to
ensure the data is private,
unchanged by any third
party, and is being exchanged
between trusted partners.
These cryptographic features
are encapsulated inside
of the Google Cloud
RPC mechanisms.
So they are available to
other application layer
protocols, such as HTTP.
This provides application
layer isolation,
and removes dependency on the
security of the network path.
Encrypted interservice
communication
can remain secure, even
if the network is tapped
or a network device compromised.
On top of that, Google uses
industry standard firewalls
and access control
lists, or ACLs,
to ensure network
segregation, adding
another layer of protection
to sensitive networks.
Lastly, since Google is
using the same infrastructure
to provide to its users, the
same DDoS and man-in-the-middle
protections we talked about
previously apply here,
which means I know the answer
to Brad Actor's question.
BRAD ACTOR: Hello, detective.
I see you've been busy and
solved my little question.
Once data is stored in
Google's data centers,
what's keeping it safe?
Very good.
You found the crux
of the argument.
Google has protections
in place to store data
in transit and data at rest.
Data stored on
Google's server is only
ever accessed by a
Google employee on a need
to know basis.
Once data leaves
Google's data centers,
there are a few tools
Google puts in place
to protect customers' data,
like custom networking
hardware, interservice
encryption,
and interservice ACLs.
Very good.
You've answered today's
question, but are you ready?
Because next time, I want to
see how your platform handles
physical security.
CARTER MORGAN: So that's it.
Another episode of
Cloud Security basics.
Next episode will focus on how
Google Cloud secures the data
centers and hardware.
In the meantime, if you want
to take a deeper dive in how
Google secures its
users customer data,
then check out the article
linked in the description
below.
Stay tuned for the rest of the
"Cloud Security Basic" series,
because when it
comes to security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]